[Musique]
alors la francophonie parlementaire ça
permet justement d'avoir des liens entre
les peuples à travers leur représentants
élus donc c'est des relations constantes
permanentes entre nos pays ça permet
d'initier après plus tard des lois ou
des programmes qui permettent justement
les échanges entre ceux des pays donc
c'est fondamental à la relation et la
paix entre les peuples nous sommes 321
millions d'interlocuteurs francophones
et on voit à quel point cette
francophonie parlementaire est précieuse
est nécessaire pour confronter aussi le
fonctionnement de nos institutions et
pour pouvoir bien évidemment promouvoir
la langue française
c'est le mot égalité car je considère
que justement l'égalité est un objectif
difficile des fois atteindre mais qui
est important justement pour la paix
sociale et il est pas valable uniquement
pour la France il est valable aussi pour
les rapports que nous avons entre pays
entre francophones entre pays
francophones qui puisse être un rapport
égalitaire entre nous un rapport de
coopération pour faire émerger le
meilleur de ce qu'il y a dans la
diversité de la Francophonie je dirais
le mot amour parce que finalement quand
on lit on est heureux et puis je trouve
que ça fait bien écho justement au monde
francophone à la fois l'amour de la
langue française l'amour de la
coopération l'amour des échanges entre
les différents parlementaires entre les
différentes institutions donc c'est
finalement à la fois un mot positif mais
aussi un mot plein d'espoir
[Musique]
je me réjouis de pouvoir mener tous
ensemble au sein de cette communauté
francophone les nombreux projets que
nous avons de porter les valeurs de la
Francophonie des valeurs de démocratie
de solidarité de partage mais également
d'état de droits et nous voyons qu'il y
a beaucoup à faire également pour
réenchanter la Francophonie pour
s'adresser aux nouvelles générations et
je crois que c'est des beaux défis qui
sont devant nous la richesse de la
Francophonie c'est justement sa
diversité nous parlons effectivement la
même langue mais nous n'avons pas les
mêmes cultures et c'est ce qui fait la
tristesse et c'est que notre langue
finalement ce que nous avons en partage
est présente partout sur le globe donc
ce qui est un levier et une force
extraordinaire que ça soit au niveau
commercial de notre influence à tous
notre coopération diplomatique et c'est
un levier essentiel un facteur de paix
et un facteur justement de solidarité
qui se traduit à travers des actions
concrètes que nous menons ensemble au
sein de la Francophonie donc ce que
j'aurais à dire à cette communauté
francophone c'est continuant les actions
ensemble et valorisons au maximum cette
langue que nous avons en partage